what's going on guys this is rob and
let's explain the ending of loki episode
number two so here's the thing you guys
were right about it being lady loki
honestly i wanted it to be icole i
really
really really did i love the character
of ikel it makes sense at this lady loki
she's cast for the show i colt is not
there were some rumors about characters
that were going to appear in the show
and their castings had not quite been
announced yet we also still have rumors
that like immortus is going to show up
we don't definitively know if that's the
case honestly we're two episodes in i
imagine by this point if the characters
haven't been cast they're not going to
be or at least if the casting
announcements haven't come out yet
they're not going to appear in the show
maybe it'll just be one of those weird
little surprise things i mean if you
guys remember in one division evan
peters character was a mystery character
that we didn't know he was there until
he appeared so little things like that
can happen over the course of a show's
life but the important thing here is
that it really is lady loki so let's
explain lady loki for a second as always
if you guys want a more comprehensive
and in-depth explanation on this
character make sure you check out my
video over at comments explained when
you get done watching this one but lady
loki is basically the result of what
happened when loki took over the body of
sif so here's how this played out in
marvel comics they wanted to essentially
rework thor so they removed him from the
landscape by having him destroy the
world tree after the events of ragnarok
this in effect wiped all the asgardians
from existence including odin who was
actually already dead at that point he
died against server in the 1990s the
important thing here is that following
that and a couple years after thor ended
up returning back to life and then
rebuilt asgard and broxton oklahoma the
asgardians were not truly dead instead
their spiritual essences were reborn in
human bodies and so thor had to travel
around the world find different
asgardians and basically wake them up
starting with heimdall who could help
them find everybody else the body that
was meant for sith was intercepted by
loki and so loki came back and sif's
body and that's why loki appears to be a
chick lasted for a little while had some
cool moments he formed his own avengers
team so they could fight kathone which
is kind of a cool thing and then
eventually loki dies during siege and
then he's reborn as kid loki slash
eichel so that's more or less the quick
and dirty history of lady loki but i
think she's ultimately doing exactly
what i said she was going to do which
was detonating all these different bombs
these little reset chargers throughout
the entirety of the time stream now this
raises a couple different questions one
what's rox cart
two
why do this in the first place and three
what's the benefit of it so talk about
roxy car for a second in mobile comics
they have a company called roxon oil
they're like the amazon of marvel comics
they've got their hands on everything
and they're always into some really
shady and bad stuff if it's a criminal
thing they have a hand in it right like
they're pretty bad folks obviously
they're designed to also be an allegory
for walmart as well they do kind of
represent just like the negative aspects
of corporate america as kind of what
they are but they're pretty bad folks
they're actually led by a guy named
dario agar who is essentially the
minotaur he died but he's a pretty cool
character as far as why it is that lady
loki's doing this we don't entirely know
i still stick by the fact that i think
that she's a nexus being but we're only
two episodes into the show and she's
already been revealed what this means is
we've got four episodes left there's a
lot of information you can get from four
hours of content so i think lady loki's
motivations are going to be pretty big
and i think the revelation she's going
to give us are going to be pretty
intense as well now i say this for a
couple different reasons one because
we've never seen the time keepers and i
don't know about you guys but the time
keepers seem suss man like they seem
like something's off right like i think
they're bad guys i think loki's
statement when he was talking to mobius
and he said if there's anything i've
learned is that bad guys are not always
bad guys and good guys are not always
good guys i think that's hitting to the
fact that the timekeepers are not really
what they say they are here's something
else that might actually blow your mind
the timekeepers might not actually exist
they might have been killed a long time
ago or even just the animation that we
got about them is 100 pure propaganda
that there's something far more
suspicious going on here but regardless
the other reason why i say this is
because loki is not your average mcu
concept it's a lot more complex there's
a lot more nuance going there it's very
similar to wand division now one
division boiled down to a pretty simple
plot which is it was agatha all along
but also i think loki is going to give
us this real first indication where we
actually see a show that's as
complicated as the main character itself
loki's a very complex character and
giving us this kind of total shift from
the character that we're used to where
he's just causing mischief and invading
new york and working for thanos and
pissed off at his family then instead
there's a lot more going on because the
loki's show is nothing else if not a
redemption arc for the character of loki
lofisson so it's cool to see this happen
and so i think that there's going to be
some huge revelations that come out with
what's going on with lady loki and i
think one of the things that we're going
to learn here is that the time variants
authority are actually the bad guys they
don't know they're the bad guys they're
following the direction of the time
keepers but if i give you a series of
evil orders and you follow those not
knowing that they're evil then they're
still evil you're still a bad guy
you just don't know that you're a bad
guy so i feel like that's kind of what's
going on here it's possible i don't know
if that's definitively the case but the
big thing and i think the biggest
takeaway from this is that you're
probably asking yourself if the reset
chargers exist to prevent alternate
realities from coming into existence
then what would be the point of sending
them throughout different places in the
time stream and how can they in turn
create alternate realities well you can
interpret this a couple different ways
the easiest and most convenient way to
interpret this albeit i think the wrong
way to interpret it is that the reset
chargers are just appearing at different
points throughout time when they're not
supposed to be there in the same
capacity of loki and moby is having that
conversation in pompeii and moby is
saying we're not supposed to be here we
could create a branch in the timeline by
just occupying this space the reset
chargers may very well be functioning in
the exact same way but that kind of begs
the question what's the point because
all they have to do is just trace those
back to their genesis points and then in
turn pick up the reset charger and take
it back like maybe even reset the reset
charger and that's it the day's safe
right you could wrap the whole thing up
in an hour i think what's actually going
on here is the reset chargers are going
back in time and resetting pivotal
points throughout the time stream what
do you think would happen if the reset
charger went back in time and landed in
the room when steve rogers was first
being exposed to the super soldier serum
and they were all obliterated from
existence and steve rogers never became
captain america what if peter parker
never became spider-man what if tony
stark never became iron man and that's
just earth right the avengers never form
there's no one there to stop thanos from
showing up on earth and taking the
infinity stone or possibly invading
asgard any number of things could happen
but these are now all alternate
realities that take place an alternate
reality where tony stark doesn't exist
where steve rogers doesn't exist where
peter parker doesn't exist and alternate
reality where scarlet witch's powers are
never woken up and wanda maximoff just
stays some crazy revolutionary in
sokovia and that's it a reality where
her brother never died these are now all
alternate universes because those
critical moments in time were altered
they were adjusted they were erased from
existence and so because of that things
start branching off and start going
crazy so the reset chargers one thing to
remember all they do is erase stuff from
existence and by erasing things from
existence they keep that nexus event or
that variant timeline from reaching the
red line whereby it officially becomes
an alternate reality and there's no
going back right you have that brief
little moment once it redlines it's
officially an alternate universe and
there's no fixing it but as long as they
catch it before it gets to that red line
then everything's okay i think that's
what loki's basically giving us right
like this whole thing here with like all
these alternate realities spawning and
popping up this is not gonna be fixed
right it's not gonna be reset and done
and ended by the time you get to the end
of the loki series instead it's going to
continue past the loki series and likely
into doctor strange 2 with the
multiverse of madness so again it's
going to be nuts and it's going to be
cool speaking of all these little
variant timelines this brings us into
our easter eggs and the easter eggs that
we have or at least some of the ones
we're going to talk about here actually
support this case that that's where the
reset charges are going off because if
you look at the list of these nexus
points these nexus events that are
happening as they're popping up on the
screen a lot of them are taking place in
significant moments throughout the
history of the mcu vormir sakhar
different places like that these moments
where significant events took place that
could potentially alter or create whole
new realities based on what would happen
if those moments never took place the
incredible hulk never landed on sakhar
that the soul stone was never taken by
thanos from vormir because you never saw
gamora tossed over the edge the next
thing i noticed is that in the scene
when loki is being assigned to look up
his virion and owen wilson says he's
going to go get something to eat that
there's actually the number 372 written
in the background that's a reference to
thor issue number 372 when the tva first
appeared in the history of marvel comics
so that's a cool little moment to
recognize one of the other little
moments here is oshkosh wisconsin that's
where mark grunwald's from he's the guy
that created the time variance authority
that's also where the superhero quasar
wendell vaughn is from which is a really
cool moment because i feel like turning
into buzzfeed and just being like are we
going to see wendell vaughn in the mcu i
don't know what do you think clickbait
like
i have no idea if that'd be the case or
not but it's a cool little reference
like a cool little little easter egg
going on there the last big thing that i
noticed in terms of these easter eggs
maybe in the future we'll do like small
little tiny easter eggs because there
were a litany of those there were
multiple references to seven there's
actually a moment where a song is
playing that's a reference to the sims
game which was composed by the guy who
worked with john favreau on iron man 2.
so there's all kinds of little small
easter eggs to go on there but the other
big one that i noticed was reference to
the avengers when loki was looking up
his file on the destruction of asgard
the avengers as you guys know were like
meek and thor and hulk and valkyrie and
all those different characters when they
were basically escaping the grandmaster
the funny thing is the revengers is also
a reference to the revengers team from
the thanos imperative story which is
basically an alternate reality where
nobody was able to die because mistress
death was killed this led to the many
angled ones so like schumacherath people
like that basically infiltrating that
universe and then turning everybody into
twisted evil versions of themselves and
they started calling themselves the
revengers but that's some of the cool
stuff that i noticed let me know in the
comments section what other little
easter eggs and things you guys noticed
i'd love to see what you guys spotted
and i will catch you all later
peace